all right we are on our way to cider
house 101 our good friend Marc is gonna
have us along for this ride gonna show
us and fresh pressed juice what I learn
fermented juice
I wore my autumn shirt in preparation I
wear my fall hair wait that's right
never touch a black woman's hair that's
how I lost this finger I am V founder of
one on one side of house at heart really
what I am is a cider guy trying to
convert people thinking it's just this
ridiculous sweet Alco pop like substance
that sorority girls are drinking on a
Friday night somewhere waking up with a
raging hangouts act Li that's what I
thought no static isn't just beer for
weenie
no and actually cider is more like wine
it's Apple one can you do bananas no
let's go inside
that's too much talking hey wait let's
go inside ER and here's our fresh
pressed juice here's yeast contained in
the juice that comes off the orchards we
don't sterilize it we don't pasteurize
it we put it right into the tank and we
let it do its own thing naturally this
is not boozy no oh that's so good why
don't I drink more apple juice when you
get it from the grocery store
it tastes fake but this is like just
pure apple heavens cloudy it's cloudy
that's good Wow let's go ahead cider
that's a cider snake all that goes in
that Farrell juice it's really cool if
you watch inside the tank a week from
now it's got its own current well I
think we're about to drink some cider I
want me some cider I want me some static
when it's all finished product we bring
it into the tasting room cider is
actually a culinary driven type of
experience you want to pair it well with
foods that is some whoa there India Pale
cider so this is a hop cider did a lot
of dry hopping in middle school thank
you here's my pleasure this kosher it's
vegan friendly this is 100% gluten-free
it is 100% raw probiotic unfiltered
unpasteurized and it's naturally
sparkling an unripe and goat cheese goes
very well with this hop cider so should
I do like sit bite wish the side around
in your mouth and mix it with the cheese
I love this cheese I don't know much
about pairing I show up to work with
like blue pants and blue shirt and Britt
is like what do
this is going to be our cactus red
cocktail Campari
classic liqueur from Italy I just take
one bottle dd junk I'm getting drunk
watching this now we take this Campari
I'm just gonna turn it up a little bit
you're taking an old-school beverage
like cider then you're giving it a whole
new spin and making it craft such cheers
Cheers
okay I can drink a thousand oh yeah it's
dangerous I want to be drinking this at
a pool in Palm Springs how does a 114
degrees absolutely yeah it's more
refreshing than the glass of water we're
gonna go to the official tasting room
over there the VIP grab a bite of that
manchego it smells funky Cheers hostile
well it just like kombucha it does not
taste like it smells it definitely adds
like a wet dog but it tastes delicious
and where I'm thinking on this it grows
on you it's getting on me I feel
sophisticated super funky white wine all
right last one black dog like dog it to
the bar are you gonna up for this one
yeah can I open it I'll drop your hand
down and hold the egg burger and then
watch that man oh yeah I look cool like
this you look super cool now that we
already popped it let's rock it black
dog it's like a creamy black lemon whoa
any vessel it tastes fresh the thing is
is you make fresh pressed juice and you
ferment it and it just gets better okay
start at the juice bar I'll tell you
what you can drink this with food
without food cold or hot you're gonna
have different fruit flavors you can add
hops you can do anything you want to it
the most diverse beverage on the planet
usually in this situation I'd give you a
handshake to wrap with the video
I'm a little tossed so I think it's hug
time coming out here no come on in
Freddy and here we go Natalie hi oh hey
guys yeah up here we made a series it's
coming on November 18th please watch it
get it here yeah yeah are there you got
it
dude I got it yeah yeah I'm not in to
see it it'll be released 2015 November
okay